[Musica]
un po di anni fa mi ritrovai a cena con
alcune persone alcuni conoscenti
avevo iniziato a studiare filosofia da
pochi mesi
ero entusiasta di aver intrapreso questo
percorso
di aver avuto il coraggio di seguire le
mie passioni
in un mondo in cui le nostre scelte la
maggior parte dei casi sono
condizionate quasi imposte dai bisogni
della società a scapito dei bisogni
personali del piacere e della libertà
individuale
ero orgogliosa di far parte di un gruppo
di colleghi e amici con i quali
condivide volo stesso entusiasmo un
entusiasmo che non è mai andato via
ma tornando a quella sera una signora
che era con noi nel commentare le mie
scelte i miei studi
pronunciò una frase che tutti noi qui
conosciamo e cioè che la filosofia è
quella cosa quella quale o senza la
quale il mondo rimane tale e quale
niente di sorprendente in questa frase
di una banalità disarmante
penso che 9 filosofi su dieci abbiano
ricevuto un convinto simile almeno una
volta nella loro vita
quella sera però ricordo che a quella
frase io non rispose così a distanza di
molti anni
provo a farlo oggi
quinto quarto secolo avanti cristo
socrate
condannato a morte dal tribunale
ateniese con l'accusa di empietà
corruzione dei giovani
introduzione ad atene di nuove divinità
e non riconoscimento di quelle
tradizionali
accuse che mascheravano tutt'altro
socrate insegnava alle persone a pensare
con la propria testa a non conformarsi
ingenuamente a un pensiero dominante
a investire nelle proprie idee ea
crederci a tutti i costi
durante i suoi giorni di prigionia gli
amici gli offrono una via di fuga
implorandolo di scappare pur di
sottrarsi alla morte ma socrate è
irremovibile non vuole trasgredire le
leggi di atene anche a costo di perdere
la propria vita
giordano bruno
1600 condannato al rogo bruciato vivo in
piazza campo de fiori a roma con la
bocca serrata da una mordicchia una
briglia un bavaglio per impedirgli di
parlare le sue parole evidentemente
erano scomode facevano troppo rumore
fu condannato a morte per il suo
ostinato rifiuto a ritrattare le sue
dottrine anche la chiesa considerata
eretica per le sue tesi fondamentali
quella che costò poi l'abiura anche a
galli locali lecce che la terra gira che
non è immobile al centro dell'universo
come invece riteneva la chiesa sulla
base di una certa interpretazione delle
sacre scritture
ultimo esempio giulio cesare vanini
filosofo salentino è nato a taurisano
nel 1585 ma trascorre l'intera esistenza
per l'europa a cavallo tra cinquecento e
seicento perché vanini fugge prima dalla
chiesa cattolica poi della chiesa
anglicana e infine dalle autorità
pubbliche di tolosa
denunciando le false coscienze
costruite per soggiogare la gente panini
in realtà costituiva un pericolo per
l'autorità costituita
per il pensiero e l'ideologia dominante
per questo gli strapparono la lingua con
le tenaglie e lo bruciarono vivo di
panini e stato detto che ha né l'asse a
una limpida e franca libertà di ricerca
ma che fu costretto al contegno dalla
durezza della vigilanza ecclesiastiche
politica
panini era in grado di vedere la realtà
con disincanto
sfrondandola da ogni mito consolatorio e
trascendente per questo nell'ottocento
fu tanto apprezzato da arthur
schopenhauer che di vanini scrisse che
era un filosofo più facile a bruciarlo
che ha confutarlo
manini era quindi un libero pensatore
colui che è libero dei pregiudizi o chi
è riuscito a liberarsi dei pregiudizi e
la libertà di pensiero
l'ha spinto al coraggio all'azione
per schopenhauer e socrate bruno e
panini possedevano quella rara
elasticità di spirito che riesce a
spezzare le catene man equide i cui
scritti e talvolta loro stessi devono
essere bruciati da chi è al potere
affinché non risvegliano a loro volta
altre coscienza
platone ci racconta nell'apologia
che socrate in punto di morte disse ma è
ormai venuta l'ora di andare io morire
voi invece a vivere ma chi di noi vada
verso ciò che è meglio e oscuro a tutti
tranne che al dio
giordano bruno
quando ascolto la sentenza pronunciata
dal tribunale dell'inquisizione disse
forse ascoltate più voi nel pronunciare
contro di me questa sentenza che io
nella ascoltarla
e giulio cesare vanini quando fu
condannato disse andiamo andiamo
allegramente a morire da filosofi
in quello che per tutti sarebbe il
momento più spaventoso dell'inter
esistenza socrate bruno e panini si
presentano coraggiosi e sempre convinti
della loro scelta ma cosa vuol dire
morire da filosofi ciò che accomuna
socrate bruno e banini è una severa
critica a ogni forma di fanatismo
l'avversione verso ogni
accettazione acritica di una realtà e
l'attitudine a soverchiare il pensiero
dominante ma non solo perché socrate
bruno e panini sono soprattutto
accumulati dal coraggio di lottare
attivamente per le proprie idee al punto
di perdere la loro vita pur di non
rinunciare ad esse pur di non privare
l'umanità del loro più autentico
contributo
pensiero e azione
questi sono solo alcuni dei tanti esempi
di filosofi per i quali teorie e prassi
sono
inscindibili e rapido direbbe che la
sapienza e dire il vero e agirà dando
ascolto alla natura ecco il senso del
morire da filosofi
se forse oggi tutto questo è roba
passata i roghi delle scomuniche le
condanne
l'attitudine del filosofo per la ricerca
della verità è sempre presente e viva
pensiamo all'importanza che oggi riveste
la riflessione filosofica
nel campo dell'etica
più in particolare della bioetica o
dell'etica delle macchine
quanto è importante oggi essere in grado
di offrire delle soluzioni alle nuove
sfide aperte dall'innovazione
tecnologica
non si può rispondere con i modelli del
passato all etica va ripensata alla luce
dell'evoluzione della società
quali sono ad esempio le implicazioni
morali
derivanti dall'uso delle tecnologie
della vita delle biotecnologie
fino a che punto ad esempio alcune
pratiche mediche sono effettuate nel
rispetto della persona e della dignità
umana
laddove il progresso tecnologico
assicura innegabilmente un
miglioramento delle condizioni di vita
dell'uomo porta con sé anche il rischio
di un indebolimento del concetto stesso
di umanità
ecco che diventa necessario un dialogo
tra disciplina al fine di riuscire a
offrire una soluzione che sia il più
possibile
del tempo del nostro tempo
oggi vi sono dei veri e propri conflitti
morali pensiamoci
pensiamo a temi come la sperimentazione
genetica
la donazione il trapianto di organi la
fecondazione assistita all'eutanasia
pensiamo alla nostra società sempre più
pervasa dalle tecnologie
dell'informazione e della comunicazione
e così ai siti information and
communication technology
pensiamo a tutto ciò che comporta a
vivere nell'info sfera per usare
un'espressione del filosofo luciano
floridi
pensiamo a come la tecnologia cambia e
rapporto con gli altri e con se stessi
a come la società dell'informazione
cambi la nostra conoscenza
interpretazione del mondo
siamo di fronte a una nuova rivoluzione
che richiede studio ricerca
approfondimento
interdisciplinarità
cos'è che vogliamo e cos'è che dovremmo
fare
allora ritornando al discorso di
partenza il vero filosofo non è colui
che vive rinchiuso in una torre d'avorio
in solitudine e sommerso dai libri il
vero filosofo è colui che è in grado di
trasformare con le proprie della realtà
di immaginare nuove forme nuovi mondi
possibili
la filosofia non arriva sempre troppo
tardi sui fatti
sarà anche il proprio tempo ha preso col
pensiero ma non è la nottola di minerva
questa filosofia e analisi critica ma
non solo è anche
trasformazione e cambiamento è in grado
di avere un impatto significativo a
livello individuale e collettivo
sì la filosofia in grado di immaginare
altri mondi possibili ma soprattutto di
costruirli così se potessi tornare
indietro a quella sera di molti anni fa
probabilmente rispondere con coraggio a
quella signora che si sbaglia di grosso
perché la filosofia e condizione di
possibilità è parte integrante del
cambiamento
e il filosofo in ogni epoca
contribuisce alla costruzione di una sua
propria forma di una forma del tempo ed
è questo il senso non solo del morire ma
soprattutto del vivere da filosofi
grazie
[Applauso]